- I KNOW THE PARTY
IS NORMALLY FREE,
BUT TONIGHT
IS A LITTLE DIFFERENT
BECAUSE WE'VE GOT
A FOAM MACHINE.
IT'S GONNA BE A FOAM PARTY!
SO FEEL FREE TO START
PULLIN' OFF THEM PANTIES
RIGHT NOW, LADIES.
OR DUDES,
IF YOU'RE WEARING PANTIES.
ALSO, QUICK ANNOUNCEMENT:
IF YOU HAVE CRABS,
YOU ARE NOT ALLOWED IN THE FOAM.
- HEY, [bleep] YOU, ADAM!
I MADE ONE MISTAKE!
IT WAS ONE TIME!
JUST LET IT GO!
GET OUTTA MY WAY!
KYLE'S BEEN DEALING
WITH CRABS FOR A LONG TIME.
[people chattering]
- THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR PUTTING
ME ON YOUR SHOW, ADAM.
I HOPE YOU LIKE
WARM RHUBARB PIE.
- THAT IS MY FAVORITE
TYPE OF PIE
THAT ISN'T A NAME
FOR LADY PARTS.
- I KNEW THAT.
- YOU DID?
- I DID.
- YOU'RE SO CUTE
I WANNA PINCH YA.
- [giggles]
- OH, MY GOD.
TONIGHT IS GONNA BE
SO MUCH FUN!
BECAUSE WE'VE GOT
A FOAM MACHINE
AND IT'S GONNA BE
POURING OUT FOAM.
AND CHICKS ARE JUST GONNA BE
DOING THIS A LOT.
- YOUR PIE'S GETTING COLD.
- WELL, THEN WE SHOULD EAT IT.
WHO WANTS A SLICE?
THAT IS FROZEN SOLID, RON.
- I KNEW
I FORGOT SOMETHING.